le problème qui se pose c'est que moi ce
que j'ai vu danser dans ces deux des
balades avant-hier sur ton émission que
j'ai vu c'est quoi j'ai vu d'un côté
l'avocat de booba qui vient poser les
choses en termes juridiques expliquer
quels sont les problèmes qui se posent
j'ai vu de l'autre une jeune femme une
influence euse qui finalement
quatre ans patron d'une agence qui
effectivement tout à fait et qui vient
d'expliquer qu'elle a créé un métier
toutes pièces dont elle ignorait tout de
celui ci puisque forcément il n'existait
pas et qu' elle a peut-être fait des
erreurs mais c'est de bonne foi ah oui
mais s'il fait des erreurs elle consiste
en des pratiques commerciales trompeuses
ou dans les escroqueries s'appelle pas
des ennemis
qu'est ce qu'elle va dire voilà dit que
s'il avait eu des erreurs et je suis
allé car un pays non ces cancers
il faut a dit un témoin il faut
redescendre sur terre quand même
abandonné je peux arriver lire sur un
plateau télé excuse-moi gâche pas payer
mes impôts parce que je sais pas qui
c'est et je les paye mais tu comprends
c'est pas de ma faute je suis désolé si
à payer les impôts de l'épais non c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe bien
abandonnée elle était responsable jeté
la clé
arrivé de dole arrivé en plateau et
venir expliquer que potentiellement est
l'arnaqué les gens mais que c'est de la
faute de booba qui la harcèle et tout le
monde à tous les sens tu mets le monde
écoutez moi c'est pas vrai excuse moi a
dit raphaël tout le monde ici quasiment
beaucoup de gens même autour de cet art
on fait du personnes produit à un moment
donné au site
donc on s'est trompé de leurs moyens
même occasion des gens mais évidemment
il y en a qui sont trompés ils l'ont
fait comme delphine comme benjamin comme
mathieu comme plein
fonctionnement il ya eu des erreurs tout
le monde il ya des gens qui sont aux
trois études appeler ça des erreurs ou
les gars vous avez l'assurance avenant
mais attendez attendez aussi on
est tendu mais attendez il ya deux
minutes on explique qu'elle n'est pas
influencée 2 mai patronne d'une agence
maintenant elle est influente ce pour
faire choisir son camp
c'est pas le problème sans âme et je
suis ce que j'essaie de comprendre c'est
que finalement shauna events mais vous
comme actionnaire
vous vous êtes là pour parler de votre
tout problème avoue d'autres métiers
betafo danseurs motion en suisse et non
lui c'est comme ça en tissu
c'est la porte vous rentrez non je vais
revenir moi j'adorais ça m'est arrivé
mais bon j'ai mes qualités en jouant
mieux
vaut des bêtises mais je dois donner
quand même bienvenu avec le sens
merci monsieur tu attends chez toi ça
sera ça ou tu peux pas effectuer
abandonné je le bon d'accord on peut
faire du buzz tant qu'on veut les
malouines ya des gens qui se lèvent le
matin j'attends quand même pire ensuite
toute la journée qui vont bosser mais je
ne change pas sas un jour maman je
termine ma direction je termine il ya
des gens qui vont en attaque qui assume
les responsabilités quand moi je me
plante si moi je plante un client je
peux pas arriver et dire attends ouais
mais tu comprends c'est pas de ma faute
je me suis trompé c'est comme ça c'est
parce qu'elle a un amant
on pose une question de pourquoi on pose
la question de booba ce que je dis c'est
que booba a eu le mérite de soulever un
lien mais avant tout par
gilles verdez cetim quoi toi excusez-moi
m division moi je sui team booba mais ce
qui me dégoûte c'est d'être dans votre
équipe
qu'est ce que vous venez [ __ ] ici
je
connais la réponse qu'est ce que je
viens faire là c'est bon je les invite
est effectivement vrai besoin d'une
expertise que vous n'êtes pas qu'il faut
tout donner voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'était la mode des antilles vagues ce
rituel a éructé maintenant booba est à
la mode et soutient plutôt vous êtes à
éructer dans une semaine casquette à
l'envers ou chanter du rap division
[Applaudissements]
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude vous
voulez on rigole quand même sur le fait
hier on rigolait sur des milliers de
morts et aujourd'hui on rigole sur des
milliers de victimes potentielles
d'escroquerie ce absolument besoin mais
c'est pour ça que ma technique des
produits frelatés mais en quoi en bois
j'ai compris je suis maintenant défendre
et millier bloqués vous avez planté les
milliers de victimes tout mais pas l'eau
calme toi alors il alors d'accord mais
si je suis animé par mam et le juriste
il avoue répond que diffamation ça
existe et ça sur votre procès bernès dit
pascal met d'accord
on avait su mêler ma patience a aussi
des limites il est contredit nous
attaquer ni confiance à quelqu'un
d'avoir escroqué des gens ça reste un
délit moi j'ai pas dit que je n'allais
pas à croquer qui que ce soit ses
premiers points le deuxième point c'est
que ensuite on a le droit de garder un
tout petit peu de sérieux sur et sourire
que j'ai à dire ça il ya un vrai
danger était là parce que le patron de
la mission va vite et ne suis pas invité
tout seul la série las donnas
[Applaudissements]
oui mais il était peut-être ces bons sur
kobe est bon pari
n'était pas brésil de quote tu viens
site
web à fabrice fabrice vidéo quotidien
sur un sujet il le connaît il bosse chez
nous on a fait un sujet permanent mais
elle aurait je le dis avec ce que je
pensais ok
tu l'as pas été
gérée donc pas ce que je vais pas été
jusqu'à 40 dans une lettre aux cris
quand j'aimerais bien sûr vous mettez
tout le monde dans le même panier mais
je mets les crocs
jalousie et ce côté chaque soin de toi
calme-toi j'explique ça plaît bien celle
que le problème la raison booba mathieu
je conviens sacrifice ne pas te plaire
mais ce que soulève booba est un
problème juridique jusqu'à nouvel ordre
le seul jury ce qu'on a entendu c'est
l'avocat de booba et toi et l'avocat
effectivement 2 et de toits de magali
bertin et toi donc et moi à priori je
veux m'excuser sur ce mode commerciale
trompeuse et sur l'escroquerie j'ai un
tout petit peu plus de
deux ans sort quatre ans je faisais
alors de se réveiller et une année
jusqu'à 10
oui j'en serai donc pourquoi tu me
choque mais pourquoi d'ailleurs qui ne
veut pas dire les bons passages au
passage lui mais je n'ai absolument pas
dit mais absolument pas dit que shauna
event ou que magali bertin et non pas là